we now know the entire list of this
year's Oscar nominees I am joined by
pairing Nemiroff of Collider here to
talk through them you guys first Perry
let's just dive into Best Picture
because we just got it it's the big one
as we were just saying a little
surprising to see nothing for things
like crazy rich Asians totally shut out
nothing for first man not that that's
too mean nothing in the Best Picture for
first man not that that's too much of a
shocker but overall I feel solid about
this category it's not too surprising
what do you have I I would have to agree
I went 8 for 8 in this category these
were the eight that I had getting in the
only one that I thought could have
cracked that ninth spot or maybe even
stolen one of the nominations from the 8
that we have listed here is if Beale
Street could talk but clearly that
didn't happen so this turned out to be a
fairly predictable category what is
really exciting I think it might be the
first time ever Black Panther and that
Best Picture category a superhero movie
is up for Best Picture we love this you
guys so deserved so exciting glad to see
the Oscars giving some recognition to a
big box-office superhero hit how do you
feel about it I'm right there with you I
was so happy to see it get the best
picture honor because when we got to the
writing categories I thought it was
gonna pop up there as well and it didn't
and when that happened I started to get
a little worried about the Best Picture
nomination but thankfully it is here it
is hands-down one of the best films of
2018 it deserves a spot I mean what is
interesting and we kind of saw this
happen with Black Panther at the Globes
as well is it sort of gets one or two
big nominations and then shutout in a
lot else I mean nothing nope no Best
Director nomination down ryan coogler
for black for black panther no Best
Actress no actor no best supporting
actor or actress so it's interesting to
see a movie in the Best Picture category
but shut out of all these babies acne
and you know I don't think it's gonna go
home with the actual statue for this but
this is a pretty big deal for superhero
movies and also just for big blockbuster
movies overall especially in the year
when we had that discussion about this
popular film category which personally I
think is absolutely absurd by having a
their film category all of a sudden we
take away the honor from a movie like
black panther that outright deserves a
real Best Picture nomination so by
putting that popular film category you
dilute the conversation I hope they
never do it because we have quality
superhero films like this getting the
wins right I mean a lot of controversy
for the Oscars this year the popular
film announcement came and went they're
not doing that
still no host not gonna you know what
star nominees ya want to get into Best
Director next because when I were just
shocked giving you guys the nominations
in case you missed them just now we
learned for Best Director afonso Kron 4
Romo Spike Lee for black Klansmen I'll
be honest I might mispronounce this but
Jurgis lumped the most for the favorite
Adam McKay for Vice and then the movie
Cold War getting a Best Director
nomination you and I were shocked
there's no bradley cooper for a star is
born in this category i am blown away
the first shocking part of this
announcement was cold war ii cold war
was announced i thought to myself wow
somebody on this list is getting again
dubbed and even when you put in my
extension of the category not even the
five that i thought would get nominated
but i had two other names on my list
neither of them were director i had gone
alfonso cuarón bradley cooper spike lee
peter farrelly and your ghost lanthum is
for the five but then i also added the
possibilities of Adam McKay and Barry
Jenkins no Barry Jenkins for Beale
Street kkatalk same with the Best
Picture category for that movie and the
two big omissions the biggest one is
definitely Bradley Cooper I mean from
day one of anybody out there seeing a
star is born I really was going into
this assuming he would get two major
nominations today
Best Actor Best Director no Best
Director now and on top of that Peter
Farrelly and I can have their spark
Green books is one of those movies where
it has increased momentum every single
step of the way and that PG a win is a
huge deal for that Best Picture category
and I did think that was gonna have a
ripple effect into director and he's not
there either
well and what's interesting is Green
Book I mean been surrounded by
controversy as well the writer that old
tweet resurfacing which he apologized
for Peter Farrelly apologizing for this
kind
appropriate very inappropriate he called
it a kind of a joke that he used to play
but he owned it he acknowledged it he
said I was an idiot for doing what I did
and he said sorry and I really admired
him because I did the Critics Choice
Awards carpet and he did interviews he
addressed that head-on so I think the
movies been able to overcome some of
this controversy surrounding it it still
got a nomination for Best Picture still
getting nominated in other categories of
the Oscars today but nothing Best
Director wise yeah that I mean it still
does surprise me I know that this movie
has had more bumps on the road than most
of these movies that we're talking about
right now and that can seriously affect
it's Oscar chances but again I keep
going back to that PGA nomination it tan
even though the Golden Globes doesn't
necessarily affect Oscar voting the
Golden Globes is still the very
beginning of award season officially at
the head of the year and the fact that
it took home that Best Picture now in
Best Picture win that to me kind of set
the tone for what we're seeing right now
well again cold war you know we were
shocked by that I'm also surprised to
see the favorite in there / Bradley
Cooper and a star is born because as
much I mean I love the favorites such a
good movie and the acting is amazing
it's so funny it's just overall really
well done one of my favorite movies this
season but I thought we were going to
absolutely see as you said Bradley
Cooper getting an Oscar nomination for
Best Director and for Best Actor and
then I thought the question would be
which one will he win or will he be shut
out of either but I thought he was a
lock for nominees I thought that was the
conversation we were gonna be having I
said we love you Bradley I did great
work and just because you don't have an
Oscar nomination doesn't take away from
that so I hope anyone who doesn't get a
nomination today realizes that well and
a star is born getting nominated for
Best Picture and especially because you
know Sam Elliott I thought had he's such
an icon in the industry and he had
lauded and acclaimed Bradley's directing
all Awards season long a glad to see Sam
Elliott getting a nomination and let's
move into best actor because Bradley is
nominated there so Bradley Cooper
nominated for Best Actor for a star is
born we also have Christian Bale for
vice rami malek for Bohemian Rhapsody
Mortenson for greenbook and here was our
surprise willem dafoe for at eternities
gate that's the only surprise name in
here to me that I mean you're definitely
right on that otherwise I think this was
going to be a five for five category
willem dafoe is definitely the big
surprise here and the second his name
was announced it's like who's got to go
here and I really didn't think that at
eternities gate was I mean even seen by
enough or talked about enough to crack
this category I thought it was going to
be a lot by four five and you know of
the one that got omitted from the list
I'm not all that surprised that it was
John David Washington but yeah I know
you know what Perry I want to get into
that so we're gonna talk about it but
actually let's move to a nominee yes
joining us now on the phone is Oscar
nominee for Best Supporting Actor
Richard II grant for can you ever
forgive me Richard can you hear me are
you there how are you feeling I can I
can hear you I'm a good cry you're
crying
yeah I'm just why Justin will run by
this absolutely Richard congratulations
I interviewed you at Palm Springs when
you were there with your beautiful
co-star Melissa McCarthy saw you again
and I mean a variety of award shows this
season what has this whole ride felt
like for you and how does it feel to now
be culminating in an Oscar nomination
feels completely surreal like it's
happening yeah if I if I didn't see my
own eyeballs and see what it was like I
would be saying that this is happy with
somebody else but you know I know it is
happening to me because I'm shaking as I
speak to you it's it's just an
astonishment and I my debt is entirely
to Melissa McCarthy and Mail hello the
director of Star Wars movie who made all
of this I share with them and I just
heard that melissa has been nominated as
well so I couldn't be more thrilled by
tried I'm absolutely gobsmacked watching
the journey between you two this Awards
has been such a treat because the way
you two play off each other the fun
you're having together
what is the Oscars night going to be
like for you two together I feel I got
one just just just not the type of
privilege and that the pleasure of
working with Melissa so you know it's it
feels like all of this is you know
topping on the wedding cake and even
like you said I mean nominated it
together I know you're on the phone with
us now as we've just heard this have you
spoken to Melissa did you shoot her a
text what is that conversation going to
be like if it hasn't happened yet I'm
talking to you I'm gonna call there
immediately well thank you for talking
to us before you even got on the phone
your co-star we appreciate it
um what about friends family I'm sure
your phone is blowing up right now I'm
so grateful thank you and Richard I mean
I guess just one last question for you I
love that you said your your you're
crying you're shaking I say that I love
that in the way of what an emotional
moment I mean you've had such an
incredible career is this a moment where
you're thinking oh my god Here I am and
all this hard work has gotten me to an
unbelievable point right now yeah
completely unbelievable I just I really
just will cause with my girls I will
cost the that's it one wrong you can't
even call our apartment that I went to
$50 a week 36 years ago when I first
came to LA I'm trying to be an actor I
was a waiter so that I'm sitting in you
know I luxury-car like now speaking to
you around the corner from where I first
did your number is Portobello Road
knocking your gate it's a complete
astonishment what a moment so full
circle and you know my last question I
have to ask you Melissa brought some ham
sandwiches to the Golden Globes and
passed them out to the people and I'm
wondering what fabulous stunt you guys
might have in store for the Oscars on
the back
you know what bring the snacks to bring
the tears bring it all we cannot wait to
watch you and you know do you know what
you're gonna wear yet Richard now you've
got to think about that red carpet look
because we're looking at a beautiful
photo of you right now pretty limited
you know black tie and I love large well
all our congratulations see you cannot
wait to see you on the red carpet
Richard II grant an Oscar nominee this
morning for can you ever forgive me
Richard thank you so much and go get on
the phone Melissa and then tell us how
that conversation goes - thank you very
much thank you bye bye
ah so exciting to hear from him I love
that he said he was crying and shaking
they the two of them on the red carpet
this awards season has been so much fun
to watch because they're like you know
they're they're in partnerships with
other people but it's like watching a
hilarious husband and wife team together
they have so much fun together and their
chemistry in that movie is exceptional
to say the least
exceptional um and of that movie can you
ever forgive me getting several
nominations this morning based on a true
story Melissa McCarthy Oscar nominee she
was oscar-nominated for bridesmaids was
yes this is her first time back and for
a much much different role exciting to
see let's talk best actor because that's
kind of where we dropped off before we
got on the phone with Richard E grant
just now so the nominees for best actor
Christian Bale for vice Romney mount
bohemian rhapsody' Bradley Cooper stars
born Viggo Mortensen greenbook and
Willem Dafoe at eternities gate like we
were saying Perry Willem Dafoe the
surprise there and then man you and I
were saying were bummed not to see John
Damon Washington for black clams yeah I
was rooting for him in all of the acting
categories I had stuck very closely to
the SAG nominees and looking at this
list right now had you swapped in John
David Washington for Willem Dafoe it
would exactly mirror the leading actor
category for the SAG nomination so
that's what I thought was going to
happen it's not that Willem Dafoe is
undeserving but I think even beyond the
two of us many out there were rooting
for John David Washington who gives an
exceptional performance in black
clansmen - so I am sad to not see him
here but regardless I still think that
this
category is a three-man race Christian
Bale rami malek and Bradley Cooper
even though green book is getting all
the love right now Viggo Mortensen I
think deserve the nomination again but I
don't think he has any chance of topping
one of the other three that I just named
I'm blanking right now when Christian
won for vice earlier this sort it was
was not at the Globes that he won
Christian Bale I know what just because
the Critics Choice Awards are fresh on
my brain he won there and he also wanted
the Globes as well I'm trying to
remember if he won in Best Actor Best
Supporting at the Globes I'm blanking on
that Best Actor so well that's the thing
right it's interesting because these
movies are kind of in they're all
running and pace with each other in
terms of the acclaim that they're
getting I don't think there's been one
clear favorite all season long it will
also be interesting to me to see if
Bradley might win now in this category
because he didn't get that Best Director
it is a very fair point I do think that
that's the kind of conversation we're
going to be having all the way through
February now now that everyone sits down
and they're not saying to themselves cuz
remember voters are human beings too oh
if I vote for Bradley Cooper and where's
their passion all aspect of oh I
shouldn't vote for him an actor now that
he's in just the acting category I think
that kicks him up a notch in that
particular category I think so too I
think because when you talk about the
other awards shows some people may have
thought I'll give him directors some
thought I'll give him actor and he ends
up splitting the votes a little bit on
himself and like you were saying there's
this aspect of I think a voter
personally who wants to be fair wants to
give love remember all these people are
also friends with each other so oh I
love Bradley what do I want to give him
here
I am also bummed not to see John David
Washington just because selfishly I want
him to see I mean he is such a
charismatic person I wanted to see when
he was gonna wear what he was gonna say
and I wanted to see him with mom and pop
Denzel and Paula Washington at the
Oscars what a full-circle incredible
familial moment that would win that Best
Picture nomination he will still that's
true good you know we're gonna get yes
I'm on the red carpet and all that good
stuff but going into today's nominations
I was very much looking forward to
talking about that movie getting Best
Picture Best Director Best Supporting
Actor and also Best Actor it is
unfortunate that it missed
one but black clans been still getting a
lot of love all around all around and
Adam driver that Best Supporting Actor
all right everybody we are continuing
our coverage on ET live of the Oscar
nominees this morning as awards season
tells us how it's all gonna end don't
forget of course download our app for
Roku Apple TV and Amazon fire we are
also available on Android and iOS and we
are streaming 24/7 at ET live.com we're
gonna be right back
talking best actress and more